vous voyez à gages pâtit qu'est ce qu'il
dit alors c'est le terme croyante c'est
très simple après jouer chez vous aussi
si vous voulez est ce que vous croyez
alors tout en descendant de trucs à
l'astrologie par une oui évidemment à
voir vous croyez l'astrologie fait tout
le temps tout le temps avant tout le
temps tous toutes les semaines j'ai deux
voyants 3 astrologue croisés parce que
vous croyez à la télépathie oui bien sûr
j'ai fait ça ça marche pour le marché
mais aussi le penser un truc moi aussi
je le pense même si vous que je me
concentre et m ben oui et remplissent
pas commencer à tourner la page alors
pas du tout non mais c'est vrai que ça
marche ça marche mais je t'aime je
t'aime je te ferai des petits exerçant
c'est un truc très fort en me regardant
la face à un triplé à quoi tu penses que
ça commence
direction gmati toyer bah oui la journée
au lit un homéopathie ouais j'y crois
j'ai accouché par mais j'y crois mais en
fait j'avais accouché par homéopathie
avec des petites salles n'étant pas le
toucher avec les doigts sur ce qui s'est
passé c'est que c'est du moins une fois
que j'ai accouché c'est la troisième
fois j'ai pas fait comme ça mais bon une
fois que j'ai accouché
je me suis dit la péridurale c'est pour
les mauviettes mois genre tu vois un
châssis alsacien et tout ça n'est pas le
genre tu vois donc moi j'accouche sans
péridurale et donc j'ai eu mon ami aux
pattes m'avait dit écoutez chaque
contraction bling bling
une petite pastille et où certains
voient donc moi quand ça sera sympa on
me dit ce que voulait une péridurale
j'avais dit vade retro satanas alto là
non je parle là que j'étudie pas au
début les contractions sais rien donc je
dis oui j'ai deux mines peuvent pas fait
tout au bout de 4 heures je vous y
croyez plus d'accord est ce que vous
croyez aux anges gardiens oui oui oh oui
alors évidemment totale avec tout ça va
avec les fantômes ah bah oui oui ouais
mais tu est superstitieuse va évidemment
sinon je croirais pas tous trois sont
sortis sinon je vous croyais que tu fais
ce métier tu es passé maintenant que de
lapin
oh mais c'est dégueulasse
est ce que vous croyez oui à l'avenir
politique de françois bayrou est ce que
vous croyez que votre mari est fidèle
oui est ce que vous croyez
j'attendais avec les grosses pièces que
vous et jusqu'au bout de filet à l'aide
de regarder sa télé se dit tiens je l'
ai bien eus
est ce que j'ai en shérif a laissé
monter quest ix est ce que vous croyez
que vous êtes fidèles vos wii ce qui est
ce que vous croyez au point j'ai pris
pour point g oui vous avez trouvé votre
point g
j'ai dit que j'y croyais incroyable
enfin c'est finalement peut continuer à
chercher
est ce que vous croyez aux
extraterrestres ben justement on parle
avec ma fille y est oui oui je pourrais
aussi la voyance non j'étais à paris
mais je n'en revenais pas l'habitude il
attendait fois qu'ils aient raison qu'on
sait jamais comment tu te dis à temps il
est tellement bizarre pis par contre
l'une téléthon luna maintenant c'est un
signe quand tu as un verre d'eau devant
l'asie est ce que vous croyez que c'est
internews va bientôt s'arrêter non
est-ce qu'on croyait en dieu
oui oh miracle qui t'a dit oui tu disais
non je crois aux miracles pour seul
effet soi même mais bon mon père ma mère
mes frères et mes soeurs charlotte de
turckheim on rallume la lumière faille
aux astres on va faire une interview
croyances on bouge pas
on veut bouger par le jingle
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas pascal bruckner je crois qu'il
n'est plus arrivé vous êtes bien placés
pour une ère qui vient parce que la
réception c'est bien ouais c'est pas à
ces primaires qui bien aidé bon ben
c'est bruckner va parler du bonheur
justement moi j'ai six exemplaires mais
j'y arrive pas est ce que vous voyez est
ce que vous croyez à l'amour oui tiens
c'est même ce qui est plus important
parce que tout ce qui va mal dans le
monde vient de gens qui dans leur
enfance
on était carencée en amour authentique
parce que plein de falsification de
l'amour même il ya des tas de parents
qui n'aiment pas leurs enfants
enfin il croit qu'il est mais en fait
ils ne l'aiment pas est ce que vous
croyez en vous
c'est fluctuant est ce que vous croyez
en dieu
dieu c'est un mot mais mais ce qu'il ya
derrière ce mot oui est ce que vous
croyez au hasard finalement pas tant que
ça pas tant que ça je vous croyez au
petit signe du destin par exemple
frédéricton raconter tout à l'heure son
rêve il était sur un taxi avec samy
naceri il ya pascal bruckner et non
bruner dans l'émission oui sinon est ce
que vous croyez aux mauvais esprits avec
un s c'est avec nsg aussi mais il ya des
théories qui sont très intéressantes qui
veulent que que certains êtres qui sont
morts donc et qui sont restés trop
attaché au matériel à la matière reste
très proche de la terre ils sont assez
néfaste
je sais pas ce que ça vaut gardiens je
ne sais pas je crois je crois qu'il ya
des forces invisibles qui n'ont
peut-être nous protège moi je pense je
pense qu'on est guidé aussi par
on est guidé par ce que l'on peut croire
à des choses sans rentrer dans des
tripes mystique ou quoi mais c'est aussi
ce qui nous fait ce qui nous fait
avancer tous les jours bon je sais que
je crois aux jo je crois aux gens qui
présentent vous on vous ont aimé même
s'ils sont plus là et le fait de vous
vous continuez à les aimer ça vous fait
avancer donc je pense pas il me
regardant au moyen
moi je continue à aimer sur la je parle
par exemple pour une personne n'est
pressé de gens croyaient la télépathie
ah oui je pense qu'il peut y avoir
effectivement l'homéopathie ah oui parce
que oui les gagner
j'y crois aussi bon qu'est ce que vous
voulez là comme récompense pour avoir
bien répondu à toutes ses questions
voulait le triomphe romain la forêt vous
aimez la forêt marie laforêt non la
forêt partir dans la forêt oui voulait
partir dans la forêt vous avez fermé des
siens ça dépend si c'est la forêt non
c'est non pas du tout c'est une forêt
très casse cou de boulogne alors chez
vous les yeux est ce que tout le monde
peut fermer les yeux sur le plateau je
fermais les yeux tout le monde ferme les
yeux fermés les yeux on part en forêt
chez moi
rien n'est rien
voilà c'était notre petite minute dans
la forêt ça vous a plu
généreux voilà on va tous nous on n'est
ce pas monsieur prévost mais moi j'aime
beaucoup je sais bien la forêt oui j'ai
reconnu votre petit oiseau interview
croyances
[Applaudissements]
ouais est ce que vous croyez au pub ah
oui malheureusement je suis très
influencé par les pubs croyez au pull
mais la vie c'est pas comme dans les
pubs mais est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui je croyais au hasard non aux
coïncidences
oui bon je pense que les choses arrivent
pas par hasard
et j'aurai tout cela ce soir autour
d'eux à d'ailleurs on va tous se tenir
la main
[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas mais l'italie l'ifa le
public est très méditative ou non un ace
compris au petit signe du destin
oui oui oui je pense que les gens vous a
préparé un petit signe du destin c'est
quoi par exemple pour voir ben on va
quand je pense à quelqu'un il peut me
téléphoner c'est pas automatique
dix ans ils vont jamais téléphone wifi
moi je pense à bruce willis réguler son
curieux m'appelle jamais non mais c'est
peut-être parce qu'il n'est pas bon
numéro brûle c'est une nous regarde
est ce que vous croyez moi les esprits
avec ds je pense que surtout aux
mauvaises donc je pense qu'il ya des
gens sont négatifs qui ont des raisons d
et il ya des gens qui sont des
aspirateurs d'énergie qui sont très
négatifs j'essaie de de fuir les gens
négatifs et l'ange-gardien vous y croyez
oui bernard proposons le gardien non
vous non enfin thomas moi je crois aux
anges gardiens je crois à toutes et à
tous parce que moi j'ai tout prix
immobiliers présence gardien la totale
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver en
même temps les fantômes vous y croisez
un moribond fantômes non croit aux
antibiotiques quoi les autres gardiens
oui les fantômes non parce que les
fantômes ces gens qui sont morts les
gens qui sont morts ils sont partis sont
ailleurs l'essor gardien c'est pas des
noms servat des morts des blessés des
esprits diront je crois que c'était des
gens pour l'alliance théorie qui le
protège pourquoi oui c'était pas des
changements c'est pas des morts ces
délits d orange fait désordre
c'est du genre
ce nous en la réincarnation oui nous y
croyait donner pour incarner en quoi
bein mètre quatre-vingt blonde mince
mais non vous seriez pas compte aussi
j'aimerais bien au moins une journée
voir ce que ça fait je vais les deux
bras de la longueur d'abord oui parce
que valérie lemercier si elle serait
incarné on valérie lemercier mais avec
deux bras pareil est ce que vous croyez
à la fin du monde
attention oui mais pas tout de suite bon
d'accord c'est un gros coup de bol au
total les extraterrestres j'y croyais
oui ah bon c'est vrai tout semblait déçu
tu croit didier bourdon et bernard
campan jeune homme cedh et non les vrais
extraterrestre je crois que ça vient moi
je crois que jour deux planètes ya
peut-être des êtres médias est vrai que
jacques chirac ait besoin d'un public
pour voir
l'astrologie oui rires mais pas
l'horoscope dévie de sa ligne mais à la
tma sera elle n'a jamais fait votre
thème astral puis 6
la voyance oui ma boule de cristal le
marc de café
oui mais parra et des voix des bonnes et
voyant café non mais des bonnes voyante
oui voyez tous ces trucs vous non pas du
tout je vous dis je ne crois qu aux
antibiotiques
il s'attend des malades bah oui ça
marche ça marche
l'homéopathie oui un petite quantité à
broyer salon batibouw aussi en petite
quantité mais en antibiotiques
la télépathie oui répondez à la question
que vous pose la analogie pas et je
faisais là téléphone quand même vous y
croyez pas si j'y crois qu quand on ne
peut on encore on pense à quelqu'un vous
téléphone se vend tout le monde vous
appelle vous croyez en pâtit pourquoi
l'amour oui le vrai à moi oui le vrai
grand et aimer l'amour l'amour c'est pas
que l'amour entre un homme et une femme
c'est l'amour entre les jours
cet amour de l'amour vous rigolez mais
l'amour c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
important mais l'amour c'est pas ça et
c'est l'amour ange l'amour c'est c'est
très important la beauverger à bobigny
je voulais garder en même temps vous
croyez la fidélité j'essaye mais en même
temps je suis pas déborder propositions
donc c'est vrai ou c'est plutôt une
obligation la visite est connue
obligation quand même je suis quand même
des propositions de temps en temps mais
les deux genres qui viendraient yeux
[Musique]
à
ces labels bouge sans arrêt catherine me
dit dans l'oreillette vous n'arrêtez pas
de bouger ou jeu c'est kathryn boole
s'intéressent enfin interview croyance
est simple est-ce que vous ont te parles
tu as deux minutes c'est un peu autres
vous croyez en vous oui vous croyez en
dieu
oui mais tu sais pas emmerder vous
croyez aux extraterrestres non pas du
tout nous vous en regardez un oui
pourquoi y est aux anges gardiens et la
bonne étoile l'ange-gardien petit je
crois aux anges et toutes les assurances
et bien moi je croise un oui vraiment
oui au fait aux anges c'est bien ça
c'est sympa une gonzesse qui croient au
fait est ce que vous pourriez aux
mauvais esprits
ouais ah oui forcément force et non les
faits se ferait chier
vous croyez aux fantômes non aux
guérisseurs
ah oui vous êtes déjà fait guérir par un
guérisseur nom m'a raconté plein
d'histoires incroyables vous croyez aux
astrologues
oui vous allez devoir des gens qui vous
disent fois il ya longtemps on s'est
tous dit non non magique je crois au
donc la voyance et tout ça vous croyez
aux socialistes
oui nous voyons chiraquiens et avec
l'astrologue - cris au vert oui au
citron merdé est ce que vous croyez à la
fin du monde est ce que vous voyez la
fin du monde est ça
un jour comme ça oui peut-être la fin du
monde c'est sûr et certain
ouais voiture et histoire mais à la fin
du monde sur certains pas l'année
prochaine ni dans le fond qui vient mais
tu vois la fin on un jour ou l'autre
mardi j'ai piscine vous croyez donc à la
réincarnation
oui ah bah tiens j'ai cette fois on a
parlé souvent sur le tour c'est une
cliente
ah oui vous y croyez aussi mais moi
aussi je vois les petites étoiles de
temps en temps je sens qu'on m'aide
non mais je plaisante pas je te jure que
je sens que je suis aidée si j'ai fait
une prière et je sens qu'on m'a aidé
parfois on est vraiment que je sais pas
moi qui fais mais parfois on est des
billets donc la réincarnation la
révolution ouais aussi et la
mondialisation y voyait la
mondialisation franck ca va etre bien la
mondialisation où je suis pas je je
crois
a gardez garder ses racines garder ce
que chacun as qu est-ce qui fait ce qui
rend le monde intéressant je crois
garder sa particularité
on ne bouge pas pendant le djing
très sérieux cette émission alors bougez
pas pareil jingle donc ce que vous payez
aux anges
oui croyez qu'un petit ange au dessus de
vous la ici la belle a peut-être pas ici
parce que je veux dire non qui diable je
préfère pas les fantômes vous y croyez
j'y ai cru j'ai eu peur quand vous
dormez tout seul chez vous le soir vous
avez pas peur je m'enferme à ses chiens
c'est pas pratique
est ce que vous croyez vous avez un
destin oui croyez en dieu mon dieu notre
dieu à vous dire comment il est une
fleur dans les cheveux
oui vous croyez en vous je veux croire
en moi et je voyais la fidélité bien sûr
parce que michel voilà michel field a un
truc c'est que la fidélité c'est dans la
tête c'est vachement bien comme vous
croyez l'amour toujours non si parce que
c'est pas parce qu'on quitte quelqu'un
qu'on ne l'aiment plus ou que où qu'on
oublie tout de suite avec pascal vous
téléphonez vous écrivez oui je l'aï eu
au téléphone bien sûr là je viens de
rentrer de tahiti j'étais la semaine
dernière et
oui je les ai vus mais tout va il va
bien écouté il va bien sabre et non un
peu des fois stérile c'est cette espèce
de dhombres de pascal qui planent comme
ça georges a peut durer toute la vie
c'est comme ça non c'est bon c'est clair
net et y est c'est fini c'est fini oui
bien alors pourquoi ils la télépathie
ben j'ai jamais eu quelqu'un qui pouvait
me faire de la vraie teli pelo
non j'ai peur regardez moi j'ai vous
transmettre je vais vous bi mais une
pensée regardez moi je les ai vus
travaillant ses débuts quand j'arrive
pas la capter c'est bizarre avant ouais
cassette est ce que vous croyez à
l'homéopathie l'homéopathie pratiquement
entre guillemets sauver mon petit frère
oui j'étais obligé d'y croire
vous voyez à gages pâtit
qu'est ce qui dit puisque je croyais à
l'homéopathie boutoille avec des
statines on aime bien sûr voir d'accord
on ne bouge pas pendant dix ans
[Musique]
oui je n'y mets dedans faire c'est un
type qui s'appelle docteur destruction
et il me dit pourquoi est ce qu'il ne
faut pas bouger pendant le jingle et la
france se pose cette question du pont
saint gatien on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle parce que il ya un mec qui est
fou s'appelle ben khadr lui il a une
idée géniale il dit tu présenterait une
émission il y aurait que des stars du x
et tout le monde serait à poil c'est une
idée des scanners la romaine khadr et je
salue je salue jack le fils julien alors
on écrit pour l'interview premier rang
bien alors oui est ce que vous croyez
aux zombies oui j'y crois mais c'est
quoi un zombie nous ont bien fait
d'accord ce qui est vote sous c'est ils
ont ils ont créé une toutes les sorciers
vaudous les où on appelle ça les mangas
c'est ça qui crée une poudre avec il ya
un ingrédient spécial je crois que
céline qui viennent d'une espèce de
poisson qui on retrouve en haïti et
quand on frotte cette poudre sur la peau
de la personne c'est absorbé très
rapidement est l'espèce d'anesthésiant
incroyable où le coeur bat peut-être
deux ou trois abattement minutes on a
l'impression que la personne est morte
parlementaire et après durant l'année
ressort gens là ils vont nous avons
déterré cette personne il utilise après
comme comme esclaves comme esclaves aux
fantômes
j'en ai pas encore vus alors je sais pas
encore je n'ai aucune idée c'est
possible si aux anges non aux
extraterrestres oui à vous croyez
s'extrait mais je crois que c'est
prétentieux de croire qu'on est les
seuls dans cet univers il ya des
milliards de planètes se serait ce
serait dommage si on était les seuls les
seuls êtres intelligents et vivant est
ce que vous croyez aux pouvoirs
surnaturels de céline dion
c'est lui parce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'anthony kavanagh fait vous avez fait
quoi des revient en première partie de
ces villes pendant deux ans deux enfants
à travers le canada
il renaît faisait la deuxième partie
devenait oui pardon mais mafieux c'est
ok céline est coupée je suis très fâché
en ce moment je franchis je pourrais je
suis très heureux en ce moment j'ai
jamais tu suivais de ma vie mon pays
céline elle était gentille et un ans en
vo states alors c'est vrai la première
partie de ben ali comme elle l'aurait
dit s'il te plaît ne me suis pas si tu
me regardes il valait première partie de
céline dion pendant pendant deux ans et
rené heuzey la deuxième par quoi et
après heureusement que c'était pas la
deuxième parce que vous pouviez partir
que vous étiez pas que j'ai regardé tous
les concerts de céline dion non je les
ai presque tous vu avant ouais et alors
pour un parti et bien parti mais je
trouve magnifique histoire elle s'est
donnée début quand l'état de l'essence
je me suis dit au québec elle avait quoi
elle a commencé à 12 ans au québec il
avait 16 ans plaît aidez à tout le monde
je vais est aussi connu que michael
jackson un jour vraiment le premier
quand j'ai vu ça à la télévision j'ai
fait elle l'a fait ouais fabien ça si
vous aimez célyne durand ah oui j'adore
in j'ai beaucoup chanté sur ces unions
ah bon vous chantez quad celles ayant
par exemple à c'est un peu tout ça on
peut tous ses cd c'est la danse des
canards les seniors aura souri
comment comment the rats souris
seulement ça commence une règle les gens
pensent les gens formant les voir juste
un flux d une mince sans visage sans
voix quelle étrange aujourd'hui quelque
chose mais quand on veut y arriver elle
va y arriver ne sera plus connu que
michael jackson s'était tu vas normand
grenier ou pas
chanter c'est plus agréable et une stat
surtout à cause du mieux chez moi
franchement on est chez toi ont déjà la
poterie pour l'applaudir déjà parce que
ce serait mal à venir
bien alors
scor continue la voyant aussi est ce que
vous croyez anthony kavanagh à
l'efficacité des crèmes antirides oui
maintenant oui ouais depuis deux ans oui
voilà ce qu'on croyait la main seau à
achat est ce que vous croyez à l'amour
toujours j'aimerais y croire j'y croyais
avant maintenant je veux un grand
malheur vous non oui oui un peu quand
brisé j'ai en fait déjà l'effet louis
mais c'est vrai oui
parlons-en non attendez on serait la
télé s'apprécier non mais là je crois
que c'est possible
j'ai un rêve j'aimerais j'aimerais
vieillir avec ma vieille la regarde et
lui dire on a vu une vie incroyable
qu'elle veut s'y mettre maintenant alors
oui
après les filles et vous avez compris là
alors il faut une vieille 85 ans est ce
que vous croyez qu'on peut manger des
fruits de mer même dans les mois pas an
r oui j'avais aussi tirer mon chapeau
des fois c'est un peu en dessous mais là
est ce que vous croyez la télépathie oui
je crois ça nous arrive à tous haussier
une ou deux fois ou même une fois par
année où justement on en est avec
quelqu'un qu'on aime beaucoup plus je
peux faire la même chose je pense
salariés souvent dans les restos grands
arrivent l'addition document
je comprenais à la myopathie oui je
crois que mes petits ça marche sur moi
quand j'allais à gages pâtit je crois
que despatie formidable guy marty
j'adore cbs dans mon pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les trieuses j'adore j'adore les filles
qui sont rieux présenter à nos croyances
si vous croyez en dieu oui
ouais mais tu musulmane baudet pas au
départ bien vous envoyons une école
catholique c'est ça c'est ça pour vous
ouvrir sur le monde
oui pour savoir que parce que n'ayant
pas une vérité vous dites on dit
toujours un dieu pourquoi on dit pas une
dieu c'est vrai j'avais jamais entendue
celle-là
pourquoi pas parce que mots ça c'est à
voir avec la langue française il ya le
féminin et masculin
c'est vrai quand j'ai toujours un dieu
ps c'est moins populaire appareil
je sais dieu dit pas un chêne non plus
non si jane birkin ça fait 30 ans que
l'enfant se dit toujours je vais aller
vers le porte et m'asseoir sur le chaise
bon elle le fait est un peu exprès en
même temps vous est ce que vous croyez
aux anges gardiens oui ah bon est ce que
vous croyez aux extraterrestres je crois
qu'on n'est pas seul j'ai envie croire
nous croyons mauvais esprit oui y'en a
il y en a des mauvais esprits
des fois ce soir il n'a pas que des
mauvais esprit là non non à la non pas
là vous croyez au personnage de la
vérité anggun vous êtes la première
indonésienne qui voit donc il vous
regarde
j'ai déjà vu est ce que vous croyez aux
fantômes
à quand on croit aux anges en vente au
mais je préfère pas cru ou sorcier je
les ai déjà vus tête
est ce que vous croyez à l'amour
toujours j'ai envie de croire
vous voyez superman ou non au père noël
mais j'y suis musulmane est ce que vous
croyez aux astrologues
non je sais pas trop le bon le bouge pas
pendant le tueur
[Rires]
vous avez maintenant ce qui lève le
poing comme ça c'est ceux qui sont pour
bouger par le jingle franchement alors
interview croyant savoir en quoi vous
croyez
est ce que vous croyez que les
communistes ont vraiment changé ou que
leur profil bas et momentanée il faut
essayer pleine relance à rien puisque
jean claude gayssot très bonne idée ça
essayez la nique à venir le contraire
mais en tout cas vous pouvez faire à la
station tous les excès de vitesse que
vous voudriez je ne m'entends tu aurais
pas du tout ma nation je serai content
est ce que vous croyez en vous en moi
oui je crois en moi et au départ c'est
la seule chose en dans laquelle je
croyais pourquoi les pas en dieu j'y
croyais et ou non oui j'y crois au début
de la course vous dit dieu aide moi ou
non j'y crois constamment et surtout
dans les moments où
bien peu de mal à l'encan vous y croyez
non parce que julien clerc qu'il est un
truc très drôle il dit toute façon moi
je crois pas en dieu et quand l'avion
commence à bouger
j'y crois pas non plus quoi parce que
dans ces moments là tout le monde y
croit bien entendu vous vous y croyez
tu y croies et j'y crois un peu plus
quand je réussis à faire des choses
et chez vous quand vous étiez petit on
croyait en dieu ou c'était mal vu ou vos
parents ils croyaient pas non tout le
monde croyait en dieu on est encore tôt
de son nom en roumanie mais on n'était
pas pratiquants d'accord est ce que
croyaient les faits des crèmes antirides
j'y crois pas encore mais ça va venir je
crois vous avez dit croire aux enjeux
croyez aux anges aux enfants oui moi
c'est les enfants les anges les fantômes
que des trucs gothique un peu baroque
comme ça à vous y croyez ou pas tous ces
trucs là elle est fantasque en roumanie
tout ça en europe centrale il soin
j'étais pas là de la valeur pour nos
cordes tard 106 américains semblent
suivre les gens qui lancent palais il
changer le
le bar ou alors ils mettaient soit de
l'or comme c'étaient des princes les
soit des dubois ce tout simplement quand
c'était un roturier ciment ne dépend pas
de la même façon
ce disque ans et lubrifiants s'est fait
toucher sur le vie de chat mais vous
avez été sur le lit de vlad le vully
dracula le leader accula pour aller voir
passer leurs vacances avec marché non
mais j'arrête je vais bien est ce que
vous croyez
jacob qui va me casser la tête avec la
mâchoire et ça va être ma fête
est ce que vous croyez à l'amour à
l'amour
ah l'amour toujours quoi l'amour
toujours croire mais assume qui se
construit au jour le jour
plus c'est réaliste vous croyez qu'on
peut aimer sans sexe ah oui oui l'amour
platonique vous y croyez siens la
fidélité vous y croyez ça c'est fait
partie du jeu du l'amour de toujours là
vous croyez à la liberté
ouais je veux y croire j'ai depuis que
je sais que je peux être libre c'est ça
que je vais essayer de faire toute ma
vie même à l'égalité à partir du moment
où on peut être libre ouais en fait très
beau aussi vous croyez à fraternité
j'essaie de voir si vous êtes une brève
française en face on croyait la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
alors je sais pas si c'est vraiment vrai
mais c'est un peu l'idéal que j'aimerais
bien que ça
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
oui j'ai pas bouger mais non mais
changer de sujet de toute façon je bouge
pas beaucoup
jingle permanent jorian et un jingle
permanent effectivement vous avez raison
en garde bien alors gad elmaleh on se
concentre c'est l'interview croyances ok
ok est ce que vous croyez que la
religion juive est la meilleure non est
ce que vous croyez que le peuple juif et
le peuple élu
c'est ce qui est écrit dans les textes
mais j'ai pas le droit de vote donc je
suis un peu dans là c'est vrai vous
n'êtes pas droit de vote puis les impôts
vous ai pas droit de vote
ouais vous que deux passeports pour le
moment non jeu ouais enfin je suis
marocain mais en tant que c'est à dire
pour les français je suis canadien
coincé quand je suis arrivé j'ai demandé
mes papiers je les ai demandé en tant
que canadiens je n'ai pas demandé en
tant que marocain voilà est-ce que vous
croyez en dieu
oui parce que vous croyez en vous oui
oui est ce que vous croyez au pouvoir
magique de goldorak
oui sinon je serais pas là ce soir ça
c'est clair
est ce que vous croyez que le psg peut
remonter ouais ouais
est ce que vous croyez que l'om peut
s'en sortir à bon à 27,2 pour l'om ce
soir
pourquoi caroline vous n'êtes pas l'om
parce que les élus longtemps à marseille
et que quand on vient à marseille
[Musique]
vous n'êtes plus l'accent et non j'ai
perdu a perdu de force
je les ai perdus ont aidé à le perdre
abbas était perdu est ce que vous croyez
que lionel jospin va être présent dans
la république j'ai j'aimerais bien
madelin penser que je peux pas voter
pour lui encore une fois c'est
chrismaëlle
j'aimerais lui dire tu as je t'aime bien
est ahmad allam politique cas pas de
cravate vous croyez qu'il va être
présent de république
non je pense pas du tout se donne du mal
de scènes je pense pas du tout il a déjà
baissé son froc avant sinon au niveau
des vêtements effet les âneries
pareilles qui va rentrer à canal+
est ce que vous voyez qu'on peut faire
l'amour quatre fois de suite quatre fois
de suite dans la nationale c'est dans la
vie dans la vie dans la dans la vraie
vie
ouais bien sûr ah ben ouais ouais bien
sûr mais elle a de la chance vous croyez
à l'amour toujours non moins quatre fois
de suite qu'ils croient plus je voudrais
un break après est ce que vous croyez
qu'il faut faire l'amour le samedi soir
devant tout le monde en parle sans
bouger par le jingle c'est ce que dit
sacha guitry ville a dit un truc lille a
dit à propos des ne fait jamais d'amour
le samedi soir car s'il pleut le
dimanche ça serait plus quoi faire
c'est jacqueline et philippe du monde
qui m'a envoyé cette blague et je trouve
bien c'est mieux qu'une blague
d'ailleurs si les envoyer avec les
boulevards aux grosses têtes
il ya 25 ans à me disait un truc ça
c'est qu'ils jacqueline et philippe je
sais pas on lui c'est lui c'est des gens
qui marchaient que je reçois beaucoup du
mail - ouais je sais je lis les gens qui
vont venir la semaine prochaine gad
elmaleh il a un regard formidable qui
vont demander votre numéro de portable
et où elle va coûter ainsi que six
agences matrimoniales ici enfin j'ai
appris ça je vais avancer d'ailleurs un
message pourrait vous dit si quelqu'un
cherche une brune à forte poitrine la
dernière fois que j'ai vu l'émission et
avait une fille sublime aurélie dupont
aurélie dupont
la danseuse incroyable est ce que vous
croyez que cette interview est terminée
non j'étais fou tu en es moche
moi
non mais peut-être mettez à l'us open
you must not move du règne de music
abonnés mais pâtit comme ça répond on va
leur faire un an ne bouge pas pendant
des heures
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ok merci inquiet ou alors est ce que
vous croyez à la magie noire
non non à la magie blanche
est ce que vous croyez en dieu oui oui
absolument
est ce que vous croyez à l'effet des
crèmes antirides
oui d'ailleurs à cognac et vous allez
donc je me suis dit bon vent bébé si
vous croyez la fidélité oui je crois
vous croyez au père noël pour les
enfants oui est ce que vous croyez au
retour des spice girls
j'aime bien baby spice je trouve qu'elle
est adorable
venu avec qui vous êtes disputer quand
même l'an prochain non non elle a décidé
d'avoir une discussion d'avoir une
petite bataille avec marc bellemare
moi je ne discuterai jamais avec vous
jamais là qu'il arrive on sera toujours
amis je me fâche avec vous parce que
quand on va se fâcher avec avec vous ces
mots qu est ce que vous croyez vous
allez passer toute votre vie avec flavio
briatore you up saw j'espère bien
belinda et vous bévinda est-ce que vous
avez tué l'homme de votre vie
o o mais j'ai trouvé l'homme de ma vie
dallas malgré mes intérêts de mes
voyages et l'offre de masi sqv sur le
plateau mais je ne sais pas vérité en
fait moi je suis ici lui il est là bas
que fait-il
où va-t-il
la bouche par martin l
[Applaudissements]
tabou j'ai dû combat fille bien
l'interview croyances et ce en quoi vous
croyez
est ce que vous croyez par exemple au
père noël
non est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour oui
spontanée oui oui d'accord
est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut manger
des fruits de mer même dans les mois qui
sont pas en reste surtout les moules
voilà d'ailleurs
est ce que vous croyez que l'argent ne
fait pas le bonheur oh oui absolument et
d'argent fait pas le bonheur
ben ouais je pense pas que ce soit
nécessaire est ce que vous croyez à
l'efficacité des crèmes antirides gimone
question tchèque de service public à sa
noblesse aussi avec lavilliers fait pas
son âge là il fait pas son âge mais qui
ce soir comment tu fais j'essaye de ne
pas rentrer je sollicite dans le bac à
glace tous les soirs je raison du
décalage horaire ça pousse est-ce que
vous voyez à l'amour sans sexe non pas
du tout le platonique tout la non non
non pas du tout non non est ce que vous
voyez que les drogues douces amène
obligatoirement aux drogues dures au pan
de toit
ça n'a rien à voir
vous voyez la télépathie ouais tout à
fait à l'homéopathie bon et agrège patty
est ce que vous voyez je pense que oui
oui complètement j'aime beaucoup moins
vous y croyez vous bien sûr je donne
beaucoup si vous voyez à gages pâtit
donc je crois cependant le jingle bonne
réponse de thierry ardisson
bien on va faire une interview croyance
non maintenant je peux bouger
est ce que vous croyez en vous dire oui
oui je prends pas ce que vous voyez en
dieu je crois en quelque chose de
spirituel un esprit in god we trust
est ce que vous croyez au diable oui je
crois au mal est-ce que vous voyons
elton john se croyant superman non non
est ce que vous croyez en george w bush
non quand même pas de commentaire
pourquoi vous êtes en france lorsque
vous voulez là est ce que vous croyez qu
elvis presley est vraiment mort même
s'il était vivant
est ce que vous voyez au fantôme oui je
crois en ces photos qui en esprit et
l'esprit pour moi itou jeu mais même
quand vous nos fringues rien dire
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
non non non pas du tout oui j'ai besoin
d'aimer pour rien ah oui oui je préfère
à ce moment là mon passé ah oui beaucoup
vous pouvez vous en passe de perdre du
temps quand même temps je suis un petit
nombre depuis longtemps ça fait
longtemps que j'attendais c'est oui
c'est quoi il n'est pas avec vous votre
nom mais pas avec vous
j'ai peur de bonbons
ah ouais
oh là là là depuis combien de temps je
vais quitter les etats-unis 1-1 ça va
être chaud ce soir je vous fine ce soir
est ce que vous croyez
si comme seule la masturbation c est ce
que vous croyez à la régénération des
cellules de l'épiderme du visage par des
crèmes antirides je dois dire que oui
est ce que vous croyez au père noël
non il est dans ma loge est ce que vous
croyez à jean-hugues noël
bravo à martigues
non
j'arrive à regarder si les gens bougent
pas pas arrivé si les embauches personne
n'a bougé jeu très content bien
d'acteurs sur la wii mais le petit à
petit est ce que vous croyez que ce
disque va marcher
oui
non mais il faut que je vous explique un
truc oui moi j'ai grandi avec la musique
de michel julien parce que ma mère est
une fan absolue
ça lui fait plaisir déjà grand-mère
fâché avec sa mère elle s'en fout elle
n'en est loin de ça non mais donc je ne
veux pas j'aime bien michel fugain quoi
sur quillan énergie une pêche incroyable
est ce que vous croyez qu elvis presley
est vraiment mort
bien sûr d'abord bon moment
est ce que vous croyez à l'effet des
crèmes antirides un pas du tout par un
effet psychologique et non mais pas du
tout physique non croyants ou est ce que
vous croyez vous pas du tout bas je
mangeais un gros déficit de confiance
mais j'essaye de ouais pourquoi south on
les a trop vous devriez il faut douter
il faut douter il faut doter pour douter
toutes mes parents soient est ce que
vous croyez au sexe sans amour ne
souffle pas moi ah bon je pas entendu
ça ça mais ça veut dire oui ça s'appelle
de la gymnastique ça serait aussi un
appel du pied de quelqu'un qui est à
cette tâche
est ce que vous croyez à l'amour sans
sexe oui c'est bien avec vous est ce que
vous croyez au pouvoir de pikachu
c'est un mec se laisse billy boy s'il
m'a dit je devrais demander ça dans
l'alcool ou croyances c'est vrai que
c'est une question importante il faut
qu'ils gagnent sur suis pas là j'ai un
fils de 3 ans je connais pas abricot
n'est pas encore banon ah bon mais nous
on connaît maintenant on est passé au
régime jim ne sont pas plus forts que
pikachu
est ce que vous croyez à la
réincarnation
j'aimerais bien y croire
non mais que nous
la frontière et oui c
vraiment
arras est bien normal nous a tués alors
est ce que vous croyez que les drogues
douces amène aux drogues dures
ça peut être des noms s'y passe et pose
la question je crois que ça a ses
raisons et des statistiques là dessus je
ça peut ramener comme pour l'armée ouais
quand il me fait une réponse comme isild
le besco là j'ai fait évoluer si le ps
veut dire ça peut amener comme ça peut
pas non mais
commerçant est ce que vous voyez marine
qu'on va se revoir
j'espère non mesdames
[Applaudissements]
quelle est la chanson vergogne les
cénacois fameux regarde mais c'est face
à boncourt a mené 3-1 pour
personnellement j'espère j'ai pas enfin
on fait un métier on est appelés à se
rencontrer oui d'accord mais quand la
gauche le single
[Rires]
ouah
bien est ce que vous croyez en dieu par
exemple oui est ce que vous croyez au
pouvoir des crèmes antirides
je les ai pas encore utilisé mais
j'espère que quand j'en aurai besoin
elles pourront faire un petit un petit
coup de pouce est ce que vous croyez en
vous oui au père noël
non au sexe sans amour
oui mais c'est oui mais c'est pas très
passionnant et quitte à parler de
patients et à l'amour sans sexe oui la
fidélité oui oui la fidélité à montréal
encore plus est ce que vous croyez que
les drogues douces amène drogues dures
est ce que vous croyez qu'on va se
revoir la morandais vous êtes prêtre
vous avez croyant donc je vais vous
faire une interview croyances
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai péché mon père j'ai bougé pendant
quelques jeux
voilà deux solutions tu auras de
pénitence 1 je crois que ma fille
offrira une coupe de champagne en
sortant est ce que vous croyez au diable
oui bien sûr quand je vous vois
c'est vrai qu'à en rire sardonique rire
diabolique bien faire j'achète pire on
vous a vu vergès oui c'est vrai est ce
que vous croyez que la france va gagner
l'eurovision cette année
oui évidemment pas tout à l'heure avec
natasha st-pier ses rivaux c'est beau la
fois si vous croyez aux extraterrestres
non aux anges
oui ça existe les hanches wii auront
moins esthétiquement et poétiquement et
artistiquement et pourquoi pas sûr
naturellement vrai les anges gardiens
moyen âge que je prie toujours avant de
venir une émission de télévision vrai
c'est l'ange des vanités ouais je dis
chouf le mois sur la gueule pour que je
me prenne pas trop syrien sait bien que
je ne me gonfle pas devenir c'est bien
des gens pas de sexe bien sûr et des
anges gardiens même au psg bien plus
grand bien mais il faut que j'explique
au prince qui a des plaisirs plus grand
que chez du chac
ah oui oui
ah ouais c'est un gros que tard et 3
quand il sera en droit il aura besoin
vous aurez besoin d'avoir quelqu'un
comme la chanson rendait bien entendu je
voulais qu'un lien d'emploi très bien tu
prends le vois très bien confesseur
auprès d'un rap ou s'il a rien dit sur
tous les hommes politiques je pouvais y
aller mais bon tu veux invitera après il
ya un an c'est clair mais y'a carlos de
bourbon 1 qui me demande si l'ego bon
ainsi que tu vois un record historique
qui fait 700 personnes tous les soirs
philippe tesson dit que c'est un génie
cassoulet judy sgro il continue est ce
que vous croyez à l'efficacité des
crèmes antirides des cochonnes
m'intéresse pas du tout notamment celles
qu'ils génèrent par âge c'est le
questionnaire la saison ouais c'est bon
vous croyez à la réincarnation est la
réincarnation non je crois la
résurrection ce qui est très différent
expliquez-nous mais la réincarnation
c'est imaginer que lorsqu'on a été
langouste ou à maroua et qu'on a pêché
on va devenir la peau dégradation de
plus en plus bas et qu'au contraire
quand on a été bien on va devenir
baleines et ensuite colibri coin alors
que la résurrection c'est lorsque vous
croyez mais un raciste animalier
terrible pourquoi colibri cmuc baleine
tant mieux si c'est bon tu vas leur
loyer et la résurrection c'est très
différent c'est de croire qu'après la
mort l'amour est plus fort que la vie et
que la création est tellement belle
qu'elle remettra avec nous avec des
corps mais avec déplaisir infiniment
supérieure à 5 sur actions des corps
bien je ne méprise pas de sexe ah non
mais j'espère bien dedans
est-ce que vous croyez que chirac sera
réélu en 2002 aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
j'espère car à un groupe qui se formera
qui s'appellera tout sauf chirac
un groupe de rock à gramat et mélia
bayrou qui va se présenter à fait
d'accord c'est vrai aa c'est pas un
technocrate c'est un vrais paysans
il a fait une très belle biographie du
roi henri iv
bien entendu nous bien il a des racines
quel charisme en plus on n'avait pas peu
dire que bayrou si les démocrates
chrétiens quand même c'est plus votre
truc quoi béchir est assez à ce point là
quand même mais qu'est ce qui t'a fait
chiffres bien est ce que vous croyez à
la mort d'elvis
non elvis n'est pas mort donc il ya 20%
mais américains qui pensent comme vous
mon père est ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour annoncé le pire qui puisse
arriver à et est ce que vous croyez à
l'amour son sexe oui bah je suis un
objet
[Applaudissements]
non non et non il a bougé au début mais
après il s'est gagné non il s'est repris
maintenant très bien non mais des cas
pas ma fille ça valait pas de problème
bien
lambert wilson est ce que vous croyez en
vous pas beaucoup c'est commencé quand
même c'est un peu là c'est un peu là
c'est un peu moment des forêts est ce
que vous voyez en dieu ça c'est une
question mais beaucoup plus personnel
que les questions de sexe je trouve que
c'est une question à laquelle je
voudrais pas répondre parce que c'est
incroyablement privé comme question je
suis croyant et je n'aime pas la
religion est ce que vous croyez moi les
esprits oui surtout dans les théâtres
je me méfie énormément de me moquer d d
d esprit qui habitent dans les théâtres
parce que ils se vengent pratiquement à
chaque fois si vous arrivez
dites moi c'est pas terrible et il ya
toujours un truc qui va vous tomber sur
la gueule à un moment donné faut faire
je me méfie terriblement et sur les sur
les esprits un jeu je brûle de l'encens
dans toutes les salles je joue des tours
et de l'ensemble pour abaisser le camp
les techniciens arriver dit ils nous
disent ici il ya déjà des petits et des
diablotins parce qu'on a des emmerdes
depuis ce matin je brûle de l'encens
dans toute la salle mais je vais fait
sérieusement vous croyez au père noël
non je crois à jean marie bigard depuis
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
oui oui et gestion et l'amour sans sexe
bien sûr encore plus bas encore plus oui
parce que je pense que peut-être le vrai
amour le vrai amour ne se situe pas du
tout au niveau du sexe mais est ce que
vous voyez que les drogues douces amène
aux drogues dures
non non par expérience je peux vous dire
que non vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
ses 17 ans qu'il était mort au 17 rue
gurs n'amène pas forcément aux drogues
douces en priorité aux drogues dures
c'est une question de volonté vous
croyez à l'effet des crèmes antirides
est-ce que j'en suis pas la preuve est
ce que vous croyez la fidélité j'espère
à l'infidélité
nous voyons céline dion je vis par
céline dion est vrai que cette interview
est terminée j'espère que non
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez en vous pas
tellement
ah bon c'est pas l'impression de vous
donner en tous les cas mais écoutez on a
tous nos faiblesses on réfléchit on
hésite
la vie est difficile quand même est-ce
que vous croyez aux pouvoirs de superman
je préfère clark kent préfet plutôt que
superman
vous croyez au père noël jeu j'y ai cru
pas longtemps mais j'ai cru comme tout
menacé finit là oui je crois
est ce que vous croyez que lionel va
être président je l'espère elle se
croyait au sexe sans amour
je n'y crois pas je le constate est ce
que vous croyez à l'amour sans sexe oui
est ce que vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
presley
je n'ai pas de preuve les souks croyez
en dieu
non pourquoi je n'ai pas réussi
ah ouais j'ai essayé mais je n'y suis
pas parvenu c'est pas dur chacun fait
comme il peut
vous savez est ce que vous voyez dans la
justice de votre pays j'essaie de plus
en plus d'y croire en m'efforçant de
l'améliorer
est ce que vous croyez en la
réincarnation pas du tout est ce que
vous croyez qu'on peut manger des fruits
de mer même dans les mois pas an air je
n'y ai pas réfléchi mais je pense a peut
être possible avec le surgelé avec le
surgelé est ce que vous croyez que cette
interview est terminée
[Musique]
il est génial je contrôle très bien
c'est normal il a conduit des voitures
très rapide bien est ce que vous croyez
en dieu
oui nous faisons des prières avant les
courses non ah bon je pensais pas que ça
pouvait aider non j'avais un ange
gardien qui a en fait j'ai renoncé parce
que mon ange gardien a renoncé avant moi
et trouvait que j'avais a fait assez de
bêtises et donc lui après sa retraite
avant moi j'ai trouvé ça je l'arrêté
aussi est ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour
non les souks royal amour son sexe ça me
semble difficile elle s'ouvrait au père
noël
oui voyons martien j'aimerais croyez au
destin ah oui ah oui alors là vraiment
est ce que vous croyez à jean alesi
j'aurai un pilote formidable mais mais
mais le temps a pas de temps à passer
moi ce qui me ce qui m'impressionne
c'est sa volonté son ca son acharnement
et sa volonté sans limite et de
continuer à y croire et d'être aussi
combatif est ce que vous voyez qu'on
peut faire l'amour quatre fois par jour
oui ah bon
est-ce qu'on exporte il faut passer des
sportifs mais vous croyez en vous ça a
peut-être été un de mes problèmes pas
trop aurait passé vous voyez sans doute
vous auriez pu être un plus grand
champion de ce que vous avez été
peut-être mais je crois que j'aurais pas
été là pour lui raconter bien moi je
pense que vous êtes le client idéal pour
une interview croyances vincent ravalec
c'est la fin d'une époque tu reprend du
poil de la bête
alors est ce que vous croyez vincent
ravalec aux mauvais esprits
c'est une question intéressante mais il
y avait il ya des chose de cet ordre
oui en même temps je suis pas
superstitieux ouais ben voyons fantôme
oui et non je pense qu'il ya des il peut
y avoir des traces qui sont laissés
inscrits quelque part maintenant les
fantômes vraiment tels qu'on les imagine
le dra-10 été ou non non vous croyez
vous pouvoir des sorciers c'est pas que
j'y crois je sais qu'ils existent ouais
je lisais pas
oui je n'aime pas moi même expérimenté
quelle preuve vous avez eu une anecdote
j'ai déjà vu des objets apparaître et
disparaître par exemple vraiment oui ou
g2 ancêtres défense et non sans s'être
défense et du tournage et c'est
important de le dire mais c'est des
choses qui après sont monnaie courante
si voulez vous rendre dans un système où
après l'univers devient si vous avez vu
matrix ouais bon ben c'est exactement
vous rentrez dans l'univers de matrix
circule le monde tel qu'il est là n'est
qu'en fait la projection d'un
d'autres d'autres mondes donc à partir
de vous avez accès à cette grille vous
pouvez modifier cette grille vous pouvez
intervenir dans la psyché de quelqu'un
vous pouvez ouvrir aux extraterrestres
sous une forme classique non je pense
qu'il ya d'autres dimensions de
conscience l'extra terrasse avec sa
soucoupe ça m'a jamais branché la magie
noire et c'est pareil je mangeais oui il
y avait vu des expériences de m oui
c'est même si c'est même dangereux genre
quoi
si vous voulez un sorcier quand vous
avez des portes en vous en fait si vous
qu'ils arrivent à vous ouvrir si vous
provoquez arrivent avec des interfaces
un peu sensible c'est comme un hacker
qui rentre dans vos dans vos trucs qui
peuvent oublier il peut vous des
saloperies vous croyez au hasard les
deux je crois à la foreuse à la destinée
comme je crois au cosmos et je crois au
chaos je crois que c'est 2 2
idée complémentaire mais croyez en dieu
et qui n'ont bizarrement et c'est là
encore quand vous avez chance dans
certaines dimensions de conscience
l'idée de dieu devient obsolète parce
que le questionnement s'élargit et vous
êtes à la foule c'est très dur de
traduire en fait ce genre de choses vous
êtes dieu existe en même temps il
n'existe pas je sais je pourrais me
salir un peu obscur de dire ça mais
c'est comme ça que je le ressens est ce
que vous voyez en vous là encore oui et
non parce que l'idée de vous devient
très si vous voulez votre notion
l'identité votre notion de l'espace du
temps devient extrêmement relative donc
je crois en moi d'un certain point de
vue quand je suis dans une certaine
dimension dans un autre je sais que moi
n'existe pas donc celle encore c'est
paradoxal
[Applaudissements]
à
qu'est ce qui se passe et ils me disent
les gens passaient déjà reçu des appuis
sur ce droit déconne c'est parfait si tu
veux la paix
d'accord cela dit on peut encore
s'exprimer
bien internes ou croyances ophélie
winter est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui oui oui c'est pour la sacem
donc j'étais enfant au lieu de vous
créer une espèce de vies parallèles
comme font les enfants avec des
personnages et où vous souhaitez dieu
ouais ouais moi c'est en fait j'ai
compris encore plus tard que c'était le
manque de père etc en fait au lieu de
parler à mon père je parlais à dieu tous
les ans j'avais besoin d'un homme dans
ma vie est ce que vous croyez à l'amour
oui oui j'y crois encore ouais vous avez
été assez tardive parce que votre
premier garçon ou l'avait connu dont
vous aviez dit cette année oui relations
sexuelles oui oui je n'étais pas j'étais
un mec j'étais vachement mec je traîne
avec mon grand frère
ouais tu vois que tu es filles fassent
l'amour à quel âge tu n'étais pas prête
à l'emploi
j'avais pas de sens jusqu'à 17 ans dans
tout le canton voilà j'avais pas le
matos je vous cherchez un père pour un
bébé je cherche un père de même un homme
pour moi d'abord cela les arrange
personne et après éventuellement pour un
bébé
ouais vous dites il faut quelqu'un qui
m'aime pour mon âme et pas seulement
pour mon physique parce que dans 20 ans
j'ai le cul par terre et je fais des
nues avec mes seins c'est vrai que c'est
pas très encourageant coin bien non
c'est pas terrible mais c'est dur à
trouver un mec je suis paranoïaque fait
avec les mecs j'ai l'impression que le
jour où je vais être enceinte ils vont
aller sauter à droite à gauche sait pas
ce qui va se passer
cherchez quoi comme genre de mec j'ai
pas de genre c'est un mec avec qui je me
marre qu'ils soient gentils qui même
crois c'est tout le monde peut poser sa
candidature j'ai ouï oui mais voilà vous
avez le site tout pendant parle sur
france 2 pour la question de la fiche
numéro 69 c'est vous qui me poser une
question
les rôles sont inversés je vous écoute
69 questions thierry ouais ok posez moi
une question c'est est-ce que tu m'aimes
à ces familles
c'est pas simplement j'aurais voulu être
en vérité c'est que j'aurais aimé être
ton pygmalion est ce que vous croyez en
vous maintenant oui depuis peu ce que
vous croyez aux anges gardiens ouais ou
séparément de son jeune gardien c'est un
fait en fait c'est un autre un autre
nous dans un
qu'on cesse d'univers parallèles c'est
comme ça aux fantômes
ouais un superman non non non au père
noël non plus maintenant au pouvoir
depuis quatre shows way à mort vous
voyez à l'effet des crèmes antirides
non mais j'espère je me plais à y croire
jean de placebo ça marche
la réincarnation vous y croyez ouais
voudrais vous réincarner en quoi vos
hanches à oued caresser bouffer dormir
ah oui j'oubliais à céline dion et alors
tu as d'autres questions non mais c'est
joker c'est cgil qui répondent aucun
ouais ouais quand on répond pas ça passe
à la personne d'un côté c'est un rituel
si je dis non à ma première télé je
crois pas en céline dion j'ai l'air con
quand même si tu dis oui aussi
est ce que vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
presley oui oui
paraît qu'il a éclaté sur les chiottes
enfin qu'il prenait tellement de cachet
de gens pour dormir pour manger pour
maigrir pour l'un qu'il a éclaté je
croyais et la fidélité dans le couple et
g non non moi oui j'essaie d'être je
suis fidèle
maintenant je te jure ça va mieux
et je vous voyais l'amour son sexe non
non quand on aime il faut que sa as vous
croyez au sexe sans amour
ouais bien sûr est vrai que patrick
fiori peut se remettre de son aventure
avec lara fabian y avoir dit trop dur
c'est rolland cyril descours est qu'on
peut faire l'amour cinq fois de suite
ah oui je le croirai confie jean le
garçon là il faut candidats l'ont jamais
pensé
bush est ce que vous croyez au père noël
ouais c'est l'émoi est ce que vous
croyez à l'astrologie frais c'est vrai
oui j'adore ça me fascine tout ces
planètes
oui c'est vraiment une influence sur
nous écoutez moi chaque fois que je lis
c'est exactement ce qui se passe dans la
banque à chaque fois vous croyez au
pouvoir depuis quatre shows sais pas
d'où le petit bonhomme jaune que mon
fils fera mal partout écrit à huy vous
croyez que je vais pouvoir ils dégustent
les vues oui je n'ai vu qu'il s'enferme
dans sa chambre dont je ne sais pas très
bien mais oui il se passe un truc est ce
que vous croyez que les drogues douces
amène inexorablement aux drogues dures
non mais je me demande si ça détruit pas
quelques neurones quand même attention
vous voyez c'est
objectif arriver un jour où les birds
d'aurélien pour cette édition c'est
terrible est ce que vous croyez
emmanuelle béart que patrick fiori peut
se remettre de son histoire avec lara
fabian est ce qu est ce qu on veut se
remettre d'une instance de nancy là on
était amoureux penser que c'est pas
possible
non je sais pas moi je vois des gens qui
se remettre très vite et ça me comprends
pas je ne sais pas comment ils font mais
qui m'appelle s'ils savent comment se
remet d'une histoire d'un pauvre quand
elle a été forte
il faut combien de temps vous pour vous
remettre d'une histoire d'amour cinq ans
cinq en sept ans oui vous voyez la
réincarnation
ah mais je suis sûr à manger une
grand-mère de 98 on prépare tous et non
eh bien si elle est d'accord tout de
suite mais je sais bien sûr mais bon
j'étais en train de choisir la forme
donc j'attends avec impatience qu'on me
dise pas ce que je veux absolument pas
la rater une bonne cliente pour l'ademe
croyance est ce que vous croyez avait
fait des crèmes antirides
absolument pas alors s'il vous plaît ne
croyez pas je pense que c'est on est en
train de la la la la la la j'ai plus
aucun contrat j'ai faut que tu as à tous
c'est ce que je vais donc j'y crois pas
je crois pas je crois à l'âme je crois
ce qui à l'intérieur je crois qu'il faut
boire de l'eau je crois que il faut se
soigner de l'intérieur je crois pas tout
ces crèmes qu'on nous vend non je crois
pas et je ne les utilise pas non plus
être obligés maintenant mais en plus les
plus de contrats depuis l'histoire d'un
scientifique est ce que vous voyez au
coup de foudre
non je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
se construit un non non j'ai envie de
dire que c'est une chose c'est comme une
maison il ya une pierre puis une autre
et puis c'est ça qui est beau le coup de
foudre j'en sais rien on et puis comme
je couche pas pour une nuit non plus
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour j'ai pas envie
moi je considère qu'on a tous un petit
temple quelque part entre les genres
hommes et femmes et qu'il faut respecter
ça fait très bonne si désolée accusé moi
je suis pas très bonne
donc vous croyez d'amour sans sex and
ont exagéré
vous croyez en dieu agnostique je dirais
je crois je crois en quelque chose oui
mais j'arrive pas à l'appeler dieu j'y
arrive pas je vais dans les églises mais
je vais partout en fait je vais dans
tous les lieux de prière et je prie et
mes jeux il s'appelle pas dieu pour moi
mais j'aime saint-antoine je crois je
voulais de 50 watts à saint-antoine
c'est mon grand pote
ouais ouais on est très amis tous les
goûts jusqu'à maintenant c'est jamais
trahi jamais sainte-rita vous connaissez
non c'est la somme des causes
désespérées vous la connaissez vous
sainte rita
hélas oui est ce que vous croyez en vous
ça dépend des jours
pas souvent vous devriez quand même
parce que parce que vous faites c'est
bien merci
je vais repartir avec ça ça va peut-être
aller mieux
[Rires]
est ce que vous croyez en dieu dans la
pièce je dis mais pourquoi j'avais mon
dieu je suis folle je ne crois en rien
mais si je crois en la vie je crois en
la vie voilà ce que nous croyons vous
mâcher avec je vous prie aux anges
gardiens oui aux anges tout court oui
gardien pas gardien y en a des raisons
je suis oui oui oui aussi oui il ya des
des diablotins lescout croyais au père
noël plus muriel non non je fais
attention non non non j'étais petit j'ai
cru après je n'y ai plus crue et j ai
recrue luis a peut-être me revenir
d'entre les marcheurs vous y croyez
peut-être ou d'autres d'ailleurs à la
fin des matches ça fait du bien
l'ensemble rien
bokolo chantôme oui oh oui heureusement
mais qu'est ce que vous voyez à la
réincarnation
moi je crois qu'on a plusieurs vies déjà
dans sa vie sera un cadeau ce cas oui on
sera encore tout à fait pour être
superman c'est qui déjà suis là bas
c'est celui qui veulent la ou superman
c'est là où il y avait dix qu'olson qui
faisait le joker
rise il avait inventé moyens man c'est
le mec qui volaient les assassins est ce
que vous croyez à la fidélité
maintenant oui à cause de vous arrêter
est-ce que chef c'est pas votre émission
hockey est ce qu est ce que vous croyez
au sexe sans amour à l'amour sans sexe
ouais ça tombe sur muriel le sens des
mots et je crois moi vrai hélas mon sens
aix aussi c'est bien là ça marche à tous
les coups fumants
les ajouts demande pas vous êtes la
nièce de michel drucker jeu est-ce que
jusque là ou là là et vous oubliez cette
question est est ce que vous croyez
qu'on peut faire l'amour cinq fois de
suite
muriel je trouverais veut cela j'aime
pas très beaucoup de chiffres impairs
donc je serais plutôt pour ses sourcils
jeu très bien passé
moi je vois que président de l'assemblée
nationale quatrième personnage du pays
ne bouge pas vraiment tout va aller bien
tu vas je veux rejoindre le mouvement
bat cynisme pour devenir voilà non non
il peut faire les deux peut cumuler les
fonctions
tu n'auras pas démoli mentorat l'a
simplement satisfaction d'être un homme
libre ok prochain coup quand je me lève
tout bouge ton cul d'accord
est-ce que je peux m'élever contre ce
mouvement ma fille parce que de toute
façon c'est pas bien ce que tu fais
parce que tu force les gens à faire ce
que tu fais un président non mais pardon
mais il est où le deviner que j'ai connu
il est où ici c'est un président delta
dictateur soit ces pauvres gens il a été
bien bonnes affaires allons-y interview
croyances vous avez raison de vous
signer est ce que vous croyez aux
extraterrestres pourquoi pas tiens
marseillais oui
mention des seuls endroits
mais planète mars est ce que vous croyez
aux fantômes oui je crois aux esprits
qui riches sont en sursis qui n'arrivent
pas trop loin ou qui arrive pas à
trouver là la porte étroite vais arriver
à rendre paradis les accès est ce que
vous croyez à la réincarnation
non ce que vous croyez à la météo
ah non là je voyais qu'il ne faut pas
passer sous une échelle
je crois que jusqu'à une semaine non je
crois plus que ce qui s'est passé mais
j'ai pu s mais je suis plus je crois
plus dans les superstitions de la
voyance et grandes décisions est ce que
vous croyez dans l'horoscope non est ce
que vous croyez la fidélité dans le
couple
oui est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
non est ce que vous croyez à l'amour
sans sexe oui ça peut arriver s'est
passé ça on va tirer un trait très mal
barré un moment est ce que vous croyez
voir clair que c'est meilleur à
plusieurs et si on est bien
oui bah voilà ici
j'ai au moins
lire est ce que vous croyez qu'on a à
faire que c'est meilleur avec une femme
si c'est une copine oui pose pas la
question
si c'est pas une copine si c'est pas une
copine dû m'arrêter là je ne sais même
pas vous la poser d'accord on voudrait
pas non
est ce que vous croyez au narbr que la
taille du sexe de l'homme est importante
sur le pas ce qu'il fait je crois pas ah
bon non non vous croyez pas et ça change
rien absolument un mec nc des yeux que
ça se passe
cependant le jingle le mouvement belles
filles n'étaient pas là et maintenant
que tu es là c'est bon merci laurent
voulzy est ce que vous croyez au monde
parallèle oui aux barres parallèles
ouais ouais ouais ouais oui je suis pas
je peux vous dire que j'y crois je
cherche je pense que je suis pas loin
d'y croire voilà l hélico est ce que
vous croyez qu'elle dise presse les
morts
oui mme siddiqui mais si c'est pas
franchement ils vivent je sais que je
sais qu'il ya une je sais qu'il ya une
une secte on peut me dire ça un ski qui
est qui vénère et 10 passes lantian
content que messi quoi est ce que vous
croyez aux extraterrestres j'ai tendance
à croire que oui bien sûr que quand on
regarde qu'il ya 100 milliards des
toiles dans notre galaxie
ouais et que jusqu'à présent on compte
d'après hubble qui a fait une photo
pendant 48 heures qui a posé dans un
tout petit trou de
l'objectif est qu'ils pensent qu'il ya à
peu près 100 milliards de galaxies
ça fait quand même beaucoup de planètes
quand on fait la multiplication il sait
c'est ce qu'on connaît est ce que vous
croyez aux fantômes tendance à croire
que
oui une tendance à y croire du travail
si vous voyez la réincarnation la
coutume de dire où la croyance la
croyance plutôt en une vie unique me
paraît d'une cruauté vraiment au total
ça me paraît très très bizarre pour
arriver apparemment pour l'amour cette
croyance arriver au même endroit cette
nuit ciel en jugement etc
ça me paraît même injuste d'ailleurs que
des gens étaient été éduqué par exemple
à torturer un par exemple un petit
enfant khmers rouges à qui on aurait
appris à torturer à 16 ans donc il est
éduqué la tenant il n'est pas
responsable de ça et puis il va t'il va
torturer des gens et puis à 18 ans il
meurt il saute sur une mine
donc il a passé trois ans de sa vie à
torturer des gens tu réponds quand ils
arrivent au ciel c'est quoi le jugement
c'est à dire il est coupable ou pas
coupable
est-ce que saviez bien par rapport à
celle de l'abbé pierre de jean sébastien
bach de la noble hélène de fougerolles
c'est très étrange donc la réincarnation
me paraît une théorie beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus rationnel pas rassuré
grâce rationnelle c'est à dire un retour
perpétuelle pour apprendre je ne sais
pas pourquoi on est sur terre mais ça me
paraît je crois qu'on peut croire je
crois même qu'il ya des mouvements qui
sont chrétiens rcar nationaliste mais
108 ils sont plus en plus nombreux est
ce que vous croyez à la météo un petit
peu web
est ce que vous voyez au vaudou oh oui
oui oui oui comme on peut croire comme
on peut croire aux auteurs de sort je
pense que ça peut exister de manipuler
aura des gens ce que vous croyez le sexe
sans amour ni la vérité au sec au sexe
sans amour
bien sûr non mais c'est à dire d'avoir
envie de faire l'amour sans ce sens de
sang et d'avoir envie de faire l'amour
sans aimer oui moi je me calme je peux
pas dire que ça dure baiser sans être
amoureux c'est possible non voilà je
vous voyais l'amour sans sexe oui
l'amour avec un grand a bien sûr
non non mais ce n'est pas toujours vue
d'une façon vers saint-louis l'amour en
couple sans sexe c'est dur vous y croyez
pas j'ai un peu de mal il faut être
solide voilà c'est ça ou avoir deux
trois jean sur l'autre je sais pas
attention est ce que vous voyez laurent
voulzy que ses meilleurs à 3 non non non
est ce que vous croyez qu'on me faire
l'amour cinq fois de suite
j'ai honnêtement en ce qui me concerne
je n'ai pas de souvenir
une excuse qui allez on va commencer
levet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
robert hossein est ce que vous croyez en
dieu
oui ce que vous voyez en jésus oui plus
facile que de conduire est est ce que
croyait on s'attend évidemment je pense
oui
ceux qui ne croient pas donc pas toutes
ces préoccupations mais ceux qui croient
il ya la part de dieu et il n'y a pas la
part du diable
vous avez cru comment est ce que vous
voyez comme pascal qu'avant de croire il
faut se mettre à genoux il faut prier et
que la fois viendra où est ce que la foi
vous est venue d'une façon un petit peu
surnaturel comme a dû tout surnaturel
juliette vous êtes croyant boue et toi
non pas du tout pas du tout à nous tous
mais c'est ailleurs jeu en même temps
jean vila enfin comment dire je suis
parti quand est raté c'est croire qu'on
sait que dieu n'existe pas donc moi je
mon sentiment c'est je sais que dieu
n'existe pas oui c'est donc le croyant
croit eilat et c'est grâce à voir et
c'est une situation qui est comme ça
naturel en même temps assez penny parce
qu'il n'ya pas de consolation
je vais être évidemment de son consulat
doit être tristes ne pas avoir la foi
non oui mais enfin la vision être
insupportable non parce que vous l'avez
oui ah bon oui croire c'est comment dire
retirer son bar à la mort elham fringues
je ne peux pas je ne suis pas dans
l'état mental psychologique de retirer
son dard à la mort voilà c'est tout ce
que je peux dire jean louis lamarre ces
dames 1 si je crois je sais pas encore
et s'ouvre à une soucoupe volante tout à
fait complet du bien à la fois
comédienne on passe tous pour des cours
d'eau
pourquoi je comprends pas vous si vous
croyez en dieu mais du et c'est
peut-être l'univers ouais et pourquoi
pas vous êtes à dire que les anges ils
sont arrivés comment est ce que je vois
les films de spielberg d'accord ça fait
encore partie de l'univers de l'enfant
vous croyez aux fantômes
ouais évidemment vous croyez pas
l'horoscope quand même mais si c'est
grave mais non c'est pas grave je vous
jure que non
le croyait la météo robert non parce
qu'elle est souvent frotte ça va ça
c'est la question ultime quelqu'un qui
croiraient météo personnellement je hais
ce que vous voyez la réincarnation
je souhaiterais sincère avec vous ça ne
me préoccupe pas beaucoup j'essaie de
d'exister sur cette planète et c'est
déjà pas facile alors s'il faut
compenser réfléchir à l'aréa garde à la
réincarnation mais j'aimerais y croire
j'aime j'aime ce thème parce que ça crée
une communauté quand même entre tous les
vivants et notamment entre les hommes et
les bêtes donc j'imagine très souvent
qu'elle dans quelle bête et j'ai choisi
déjà c'est quoi oui j'ai choisi au bas
j'en parle avec mon fils l'éléphant
geler les pensions laisse un peu
tranquille les défendent affreuse et son
magnifique c'est le plus bel animal
impression c'est toute la mémoire du
monde
est ce que vous croyez à la fidélité
dans le couple c'est rien et
systématique toucher à votre avis moi je
sais pas mais ça dépend du couple et je
crois simplement qu'il faut pas qu'il ya
un voleur est un imbécile c'est tout est
ce que croyait le sexe sans amour
ben évidemment c'est à dire que ces
pages c'est pas que je veux ou ne pas y
croire mais c'est une nécessité ou
rendez compte on rêve tous d'un amoureux
de ternell etc mais en attendant de
rencontrer et moi je les rencontrais
avec ma femme donc ça va les souks royer
à l'amour sans sexe robert à l'amour des
autres ou est à prendre en charge les
autres et les appels au secours
et tout ce qu'on voit et l'humiliation
des autres et la solitude des autres d'y
croire mais alors à 100% même peut-être
monsieur noah
dans un certain progressisme il va bien
s'entendre avec juliette binoche est ce
que vous preniez robert hossein que ses
meilleurs à plusieurs eh bien écoutez
moi je suis encore béotien mais je vous
fais confiance est la meilleure le pote
de vadim
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous croyez en dieu je crois
en dieu pas l'interprétation qu'on peut
en faire nous extra terrestre je crois
qui je crois que la vie est aussi elle
est aussi là et elle est aussi ailleurs
oui aux fantômes ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur
pourquoi y'a plein de trucs en fait je
croyais en la météo question non mais ça
dépend sur quelle chaîne est ce que vous
croyez à l'effet des crèmes antirides
oui je vais à certaines est ce que vous
croyez à l'horoscope sarah sand ça je
crois je crois à l'horoscope des
sarrasins ça rassemble tous ses clients
misez pas gala si mais pas que ça
l'avant dernière passe et le pouce comme
avant
émission cette fois la salle salusse
est ce que vous voyez est ce que vous
croyez à la fidélité dans le couple
je crois à la fidélité j'ai super tu
n'es pas fidèles en gros quoi c'est pas
ça je pense que je pense que après vingt
ans de mariage
je pense qu'il est parfois il va y avoir
des petits et des grands écarts donc le
petit peu je pense que après l'attitude
qu'on peut avoir dans la vie et qu'on
peut avoir par exemple la discrétion
pour un homme qui trompe sa femme
la discrétion dans dans ce genre d'actes
et la marque de respect que l'on peut
voilà est-ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour
pas pour moi je ne veux pas et là mon
sens aix ou non plus parce que ça
suffise le plus ou le couple jusqu'à
vous voyez à l'homosexualité
j'ai essayé n'ont jamais mais plein de
trucs à découvrir
oui tout à fait le mélangisme vous avez
essayé expliquez moi j'ai mis le
mélangisme hors options quand on est
quatre de coups comme ça dans un salon
un peuple un peu dénudée restez pas
vraiment de l'échangisme
c'est du mélange est question de la
fiche 69
donc c'est vous qui allez me posais une
question nadia face
maintenant que je suis ici assise en
face de vous thierry pensez-vous
toujours que je ne vous avais pas non
maintenant non maintenant je trouve très
bien très naturelle je pense que même eh
bien oui rien que ça ça va marcher là
salaire de plaintes ou les gars et oui
et oui mais malheureusement si les
radios ne passe pas ça va pas en faire
une grève de la faim pour il le passe
vous voulez qu'on aille séquestré
guazzini des gens comme ça non max
guazzini
on est pris à tous on est prêtes saisis
en plus de mon milliardaire quand
j'avais le sens exact mans le sosie de
tu nous a dit qu'il était beau
ne bougez pas on ne bouge pas pendant le
génial adrian a interdit croyance est ce
que vous croyez à la fidélité dans le
couple pascale en virage et il a mérité
avait absolument
est ce que vous croyez qu'en cas de
petit écart
il faut le dire à l'autre ça dépend
qu'est ce que tu entends un petit écart
le petit écart mais tu veux préciser sa
pensée si j'étais coup de canif dans le
contrat comment hinter le dis les choses
ça dépend si en fait c'est que nous
aussi on veut qu'on est dans la merde
tous les deux vont mieux pas se dire
peut-être est-ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour sexe sans amour
oui mais ça peut être beaucoup mieux
avec glamour mais dites-moi quand même
donc la porte et ovins
comme moi bien sûr
est ce que vous croyez à l'amour sans
sexe beaucoup ont blessé si j'imagine
encore mon partenaire pas avoir accident
quelque chose de mal
oui réducteur par exemple déjà un
adducteur si handicapant alors mon
bonheur il peut perdre le ballon
tout va bien
mais tout va bien je vous assure non
vraiment si c'était quelque chose plus
grave je dis oui bon est ce que vous
croyez adriana karembeu que faire mal à
son partenaire peut faire du bien
oui cela faisait 20 40
je les adore vous serez invités jusqu'à
la fin des temps dans cette nuit
est ce que vous croyez qu avoir mal soi
même peut faire du bien
oui est ce que vous croyez adriana
karembeu qu'on peut faire l'amour
agréablement tout seul agréable
agréablement mais monsieur c'est pas
génial
ouais ouais mais oui est ce que vous
croyez que c'est meilleur à plusieurs
n'ont rien à faire les quatre pilotes
donc on va rester dans le domaine de
votre film
pour cette intel ou croyance est ce que
vous croyez que le sexe c'est de la
comédie
je pense que oui parce que je pense
qu'on fait une confusion beaucoup entre
l'amour et la sexualité
voire même la sexualité est un ennemi de
l'amour et que l'amour tout ce qu'il a
de solides et de profond et devrait et
d'acceptation de l'autre en commun vont
tourner en comparaison à la sexualité
qu'est la séduction qui est le jeu de la
séduction le jeu génial je injustement
vous croyez au sexe sans amour et vous
croyez aussi à l'amour sans sexe oui et
à en disant que le miracle étant pouvoir
lier les deux mais rarissime un
rarissime avec grâce et harmonie parce
qu'on peut à tout prix
il faut conserver la trace est ce que
vous croyez la fidélité dans le couple
non pas trop non non c'est magnifique
comme ils disent mais c'est une idée est
ce que vous croyez justement qu'en
cadets car il faut le dire je trouve que
ça serait très bien parce que je trouve
voilà la différence sur l'amour et la
sexualité c'est que si on pouvait vivre
avec quelqu'un qui nous accepte vraiment
dont qui acceptent les déviations les
obsessions les perversions et ça et
qu'on puisse confier enfin au lieu
d'aller chez un psy ou ailleurs ou à sa
copine dire la personne qui vous dit
vous aimez lui dire voilà ce que tu
aimes et que cette personne n'accepte
vous pouvez commencer à croire à l'amour
est ce que vous croyez que faire mal
peut faire du bien
oui parce que je pense qu'il suffit de
remplacer les valeurs au sens nous
apprendrons nous apprend des codes mais
on peut essayer de transformer l'école
et ils découvrirent tout à fait notre
réalité ans par exemple
par exemple je pense pas parce que c'est
l'exemple le plus évident pour illustrer
mais si vous prenez le sado masochistes
justement dit ce que je pensais
voilà la philosophie qui est véhiculé
derrière ça et pas c'est quand même des
gens qui ont transformé la douleur en
plaisir mais ce n'est pas qu'au niveau
physique c'est au niveau cérébral et là
ça devient vraiment intéressant
donc vous voyez que faire mal peut faire
du bien et qu avoir mal peut faire du
bien aussi
je pense qu'il faut tout prendre est ce
que vous voyez ces meilleurs à plusieurs
on va dire oui on va dire oui à tout en
fait parce qu'on va prendre la base de
la curiosité de la recherche humaine et
qu'à partir de là tout est intéressant
d'aller découvrir
vous pensez que c'est d'ailleurs
plusieurs à penser que c'est meilleur
avec une femme
la réponse paraît faut tout essayer
alors est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut
faire l'amour en regardant cette
émission
oui il ya beaucoup de gens qui le font
et je suis sûr qu'on va se propose qu'on
fasse un petit break qu'on me donne
essuie-glaces hurler on passe quelque
chose
vas-y tu vas faire déborder tout le
monde doit pas une minute pour ça ça y
est ça y est c'est fini au delà quand
elle va aller en chine
c'est ça le service public ça y est non
non il y en a un autre dans les gènes
les pétoires
aulnoye on n'attend pas les parents à
les sessions fait pas peur que sa simple
buzz
est ce que vous croyez en vous parce que
vous croyez en dieu
oui est ce que vous croyez quand je vous
dis que je n'ai jamais ressenti ça pour
quelqu'un d'autre que vous mentez
est ce que vous croyez que les hommes
simulent parfois comme les femmes comme
les femmes pensaient que les hommes ça
peut simuler est ce que vous croyez
qu'un jour vous allez être une énorme
vedette
je sais pas si je serai une énorme
vedette mais en tout cas il ya un truc
qui est important c'est que il oscar
wilde disait qu'il faut avoir du du du
talent dans sa vie professionnelle et du
génie dans sa vie privée je crois que
j'ai un peu de génie dans ma vie privée
en ce moment donc ça me va comme ça
explique rien lhadji badiane
je fais des choses intéressantes je
travaille je rencontre des gens
passionnants ma vie privée se passe bien
donc
donc pour l'instant c'est bien à vous
comprenez bien on veut pas en rester là
mais je comprends bien tiré mais d'un
autre côté vous n'êtes pas non plus
journaliste à voici je ne ferai pas la
peine dans ce genre de discussion ça se
passe bien ça se passe bien donc voilà
c'est à dire que maintenant ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est de réussir ma
vie
et puis d'une femme ma vie de femme mais
j'ai envie aussi de faire une carrière
est de faire encore des beaux films mais
c'est pas le plus important maintenant
est ce que vous pensez que vos seins
sont un atout dans votre carrière
je pense qu'ils n'ont plus fait chier
que que l' inverse les deux la commande
mais rien n'a pas trois est-ce que vous
pouvez tout jouer je pense que je peux
tout joué que malheureusement à cause de
chochana boutboul y en a quelques-uns
qui pensent que je ne peux être que
shoshana c'est pour ça l'histoire des
chemins d'art est alors il est comment
alors est beau ah bon il fait bien
l'amour tirer oui c'est vrai chéri est
ce que vous croyez au père noël
je ne crois pas au père noël non je vous
croyais que zidane bois vraiment de la
volvic non mais je crois que par contre
ça lui a rapporté beaucoup de zèle
est-ce que vous croyez ce que vous voyez
au journal télévisé
oui et puis après quand on change de
pays et que les données sont un peu
différentes je me disent qu'ils se
foutent tous bien de nous quand même
est-ce que vous croyez à la fidélité
dans le couple
j'en sais rien c'est une ouverture non
j'en sais rien je pense que c'est des
questions un peu un peu idiote
non non non non non pas présentement va
maintenant peut-être que ça existe elle
peut-être je sais pas moi allez ça
existe ça existe ou est positif pourquoi
avoir l'amour pendant le travail
j'y voyais d'amour sur les plateaux de
télévision
en séries les coureurs il est courant
non pas du tout vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
oui pendant le travail sur plateau
trouver l'amour sans sexe est en
revanche de quoi les pas du tout soyez
honnête 5 l'amour sans amour platonique
ce n'est pas votre truc voilà je suis
pas je n'avais jamais essayé de
puissants gens c'est vrai est ce que
croyait l'homéopathie oui ah ouais moi
j'ai un ostéopathe gemalodo donne des
trucs homéopathique jeu mais c'est bien
d'autres séances salaire et on perd
c'est beau il
est-ce que les drogues douces amène
forcément aux drogues dures
je suis pas d'avis là dessus je suis en
défense et je suis très fier qu'on
rigole est-ce que vous pouvez que
j'espère va revenir un jour non je crois
pas ah bon tu crois que je sois va
revenir un jour toi j'ai fait un pari
sur les élections présidentielles de
2007 mois et du coup qu'ils seraient
présents
tu vas pas qu'ils reviennent je sais que
le pari de dante leur lait il intérêt à
se représenter sur ça je perd gros moi
j'ai parié gros sur jospin 2007
il est tellement suffisant est tellement
sûr de lui pour ça me semble impossible
qui laisse tomber la politique ou couac
jospin à revenir mais je ne sais rien de
ça
attention est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui est ce que vous croyez au diable non
est ce que vous croyez que dans l'avenir
tout le monde se rhabiller avec des
combinaisons argentées
non car bien sûr si si tous une âme est
ce que vous croyez au voyage dans le
temps non si le voyage dans le temps
avait existé des voyageurs du futur
seraient déjà venus nous voir oui tu as
raison personnelle juste est ce que vous
croyez aux extraterrestres oui vous
croyez extraterrestre complètement oui
parce qu'avoir là c'est une bonne
croyance c'est une certitude
scientifique parce que je regardais la
population vous êtes et ce que vous
croyez qu'on peut se réincarner dans un
meuble par exemple non non est ce que
vous croyez à la colonisation de mars
oui oui oui madame à l'antenne deux fois
est ce que vous croyez la force comme
dans star wars
oui parce qu'en fait la force dans un
certain sens c'est la quintessence donc
jusqu'à apprennent tout à l'heure c'est
la force option énergie noire énergie
noire
est ce que vous croyez si ça se trouve
que l'humanité n'est que le rêve d'un
chien non non est ce que vous croyez aux
fantômes vampires loups garous à toutes
ces conneries
non ce sont des personnages de la
réalité fantastique ils sont faits pour
être admiré dans les romans en fait mais
pas mais il existe pas du tout d'accord
nous ne venons pas ici stance est ce que
vous croyez à l'innocence de michael
jackson
j'aurais tendance à dire j'aurais
tendance à dire à sa place qu'on ne sort
de l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment donc
c'est pas la peine de s que vous voyez à
une quatrième dimension
oui bah oui oui bah oui mais oui puisque
toutes les attentions former une 6e
temps en panne si non il ya bien cinq
après la cinquième est ce que vous
croyez aux chaussettes blanches avec des
mocassins
ça dépend comme elles sont portés mais
oui quand même une thèse à tuer moi non
mais lui est ce que vous croyez que le
clonage devrait être accessible à tous à
part pour les piliers non non non non
c'est strictement non d'ailleurs il n'ya
pas d'avenir dans le clonage qu'on n'a
vraiment pas non parce que c'est une
illusion
tous les temps du clonage nous nous en
fait c'est pas mal ça c'est une carte de
clown
donc le clonage qui croit pas du tout
non seulement j'y crois pas mais je
trouve que c'est une illusion de dire
bravo
il existe en ce moment des aux états
unis par exemple une société qui
commercialise des des animaux en les
clones ans et en disant voilà c'est la
reproduction de votre de votre animal
favori or c'est tout à fait faux parce
que quand on prend par exemple un choc
qui avait une tache au bout de la queue
elle se retrouve sur la seule gauche
médias chiffres un chat ou un chien
peu importe mais en tout cas en tout cas
dans le codage de l'animal alors que
tous les caractères sont supposés être
les mêmes il se trouve que des processus
aléatoires intervienne et que l'animal
n'est jamais le même
donc c'est déjà une imposture au départ
non alors dernière question la plus
importante est ce que vous croyez le
métier au d'evelyne dhéliat à la météo
en fait pas tellement parce que là aussi
et des phénomènes aléatoires et qui font
qu'on n'est pas capable encore
aujourd'hui de prévoir quoi que ce soit
en interview avait été scié non en fait
non plus c'était le palais l'est
davantage c'est vrai
[Musique]
ah qu est ce que vous croyez en vous oui
est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui je les ai vu trois fois je les ai
vus j'ai vu qu'on ne riez pas seulement
les incrédules
quand j'ai eu 20 tentes pendant un dry
sont pas dans une partie de foot sur la
latte sur la touche au posta de pershing
c'était un soleil colossal il était
projeté devant celui que tous les 20 ans
g7 privilège de le voir et la radio x
la deuxième fois c'était une immense
pyrale rouge était dans un taxi
troc et place de la concorde et j'ai été
j'ai entendu cette voix qui me disait
veux tu me vois encore julie oui mais
c'était c'est encore c'est à l'intérieur
du corps commentant cette joie oui moi
j'ai dit oui mais à l'intérieur surtout
le tueur le chauffeur de taxi de thaksin
n'attendent rien et je les fêtards
éméchés une seconde je parle avec des
jeux des projeté pas de sacrilège vous
allez avoir des pépins dans votre vie
comprendre à tanger pas qu accor 6 il
fait signe de la croix d'accord mais moi
je pense que si dieu existe je pense
qu'il a de l'humour en tout cas jamais
jeu là dessus
il est oui et c'était une immense pyrale
rouge bien et m'a pris ce que la villa
ce pirate la chaleur et mappy des tas de
trucs et la troisième fois c'était dans
une voiture rouler cette fois ci le
départ été et serons voiture et il m'a
appris il m'a montré un immense jusqu'à
l'infini il y avait des perles roses
doré comme ça qui s'étend à l'infini
il m'a dit vous les humains vous pensez
que votre continuum espace temps et la
seule chose que j'ai créé mes jeux créés
depuis l'infini jusqu'à l'éternité
et voilà ton monde et un de ces mondes
il a montré une boule comme ça au petit
mot espace temps à manger vu une
exploser un bang big caps nôtres ceux
réalisés dit et s'écrit tu vas voir les
pièces en mer de monde mais dans la vie
de moine à je vais pas de toi j'aime
l'aventuré vous avez le droit de jeu de
maillots
les gros yeux ça fait peur allez
continuez ne fait heureusement ce que
vous est-ce que vous suivez là est-ce
que vous mais moi j'ai du mal mais je
pense je pense à aucun moment qui se
moque de narbonne non mais je pensais
qu'au mans et le sonar
moquée de dieu on peut le revoir les
images comme nous n'avons pas eu la
chance d'avoir et d'avoir vécu cette
expérience dans un taxi le nord et pour
le tati aglukkaq mais on s'appelle on a
le droit de se renseigner quand même
bien sûr bien sûr qu est ce que vous
croyez
c'est une reine anglaise et je voudrais
l'anglais est ce que vous croyez que les
femmes simulent parfois je pense que oui
parce quoi parfois rarement mais parfois
les souks royer au trèfle à quatre
feuilles aux pattes de lapin en touche
du bois tout ça vous croyez pas non
nous croyons aux anges gardiens oui oui
je lui en ai vu les extraterrestres j'en
ai vu à bord a apprécié un taxi
dans un bus en essayant ça fait des
années qu il ya des gens qui passent qui
traverse la vie en regardant leurs
chaussures ou le sol saturé les gens
tous les gens qui ont des problèmes de
fric ou des problèmes de mal d'être
garde toujours le sol veut vérifier les
gens dans la rue et il ya les autres les
poètes et les liens qu'ils regardent le
ciel
et quand vous vous levez le le regarde
le ciel vous voyez des choses quitte
pour un poteau il ya deux ans huit
autres jettent un oeil sur le ciel l'on
regarde on marche on est la créature de
roswell
c'est une vraie arrêt on le sait ça
allait pas à l'époque
il ya une émotion chez les mecs pour toi
pourquoi là
hoffmann comme par hasard avec
rockefeller ont-ils créé la cia comme
par hasard en 47
tout de suite après le crash de roswell
l'arrêté se recoupent on est content
pradel avait raison oui il existe près
d'elle je débuterai télé est ce que vous
croyez au marabout non aux bouts de
ficelle à l'astrologie on joue pas un
personnage qu'on est fait par des gens
sérieux par exemple françoise hardy le
fait très bien très bien vous êtes de
quel signe vos verso comme mozart
je sais pas mais en même temps comme
jusqu'à celle interne qui joue des
musiques je sais je sais ce qu'est ce
qu'un seul aujourd'hui est ce que vous
croyez aux fantômes
oui j'en ai eu beaucoup mais sympa y en
a des sympas ils sont tous sympas il y
en a qui sont bloqués avec son bloc et
lancer des âmes qui meurt et au moment
où vous m'aurez il aime tellement la vie
il s'accroche à la vie dont il se dit
que touche pas du corps et il s'accroche
aux meubles hauts lieux et ma nièce qui
a cinq ans on a vu comme moi mais on y
re plusieurs jeunes j'avais un château
le château de palu et sont toujours les
chalets sont jamais au camping ne
comprends pas
pourquoi ya pas de temps d'attenté
fantôme vous avez dans un endroit
brusquement dans une pièce fermée vous
allez voir les modes qui tombe le chat
qui se dressent hérissé et qui regardent
comme si tu étais un passé dans la pièce
phare des chats voit des fantômes et
vous et protéger les gens et vous avez
ce château tallio on peut pas dormir
dans des chambres car les portes
claquent et se refermer les tiroirs
sautet et même des dégâts
un kit est vraiment très pragmatiques
ils n'ont pas pu dormir dans cette
chambre et ont diminué de l'année sont
levés en hurlant de terreur parce que il
y avait ce phénomène notable mais car ce
serait nier qu'il ya des fantômes dans
son château bien sûr dans tous les
châteaux
vous croyez aux vampires non non assez
marrant ça non c'est une histoire
inventée
vous y croyez le père noël alors oui la
wii ça me fait penser je n'ai vu aucun
de la fillette
est ce que vous voyez au journal
télévisé je suis fervent je ne regarde
que je suis là le zappeur le plus
invraisemblable d'issoire est ce que
vous croyez à l'effet des crèmes anti
rides plus dure déjà
non mes soeurs con comme moi une pop art
idée parce que notre grand mère nous
avez appris à nous laver sans savon
jamais jamais de savon à l'eau chaude
l'eau bouillante
le gant de toilette tremper dans l'eau
bouillante que vous passez sur le visa
jamais de savon
mes soeurs n'ont pas une ride est
limpide pour non plus ils sont
magnifiques avant mais à chaud de la
môle il a pour principe séquence fouad
qui maintient la peau à l'eau chaude
après noël de faire fondre de sébum tous
décédés après la fidélité dans le couple
ayant eu un oui oui oui j'en connais
beaucoup mes soeurs par exemple a ri
quand même temps auxerre bat ou plus
depuis qu'ils se sont mariés non jeu ça
fait quoi
j'avais déjà 35 ans 45 ans ont baisé
ailleurs non se sont mariés vierge à la
haye était via je ne vais pas toucher
j'ai mon ange gardien quim envoie un
texto la merci beaucoup vous êtes au top
amitié sincère le lot boyer merci mon
héros
alors est ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
ouais ça s'appelle la baise ah bon et à
ces sahraouis ont fait de l'amour avec
la femme que l'on aime et on baise les
filles de rencontre c'est totalement
différent et c'est un donc c'est un sexe
sans amour
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous
filent pas le ministère de l'éducation
nationale men série tellement de trucs
non mais c'est vrai
est ce que vous croyez par exemple que
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
l'argent peut être la chose la plus
dangereuse exemple le le loto avec ces
sommes insensé combien de gens se sont
suicidé parce qu'ils ont eu trop de fric
ils n'ont pas su gérer cet argent il ya
quand même beaucoup plus de gens qui se
suicident parce que j'en avais pas
si on regarde les chiffres un peu je
prends pas ça tour about me croyez que
les drogues douces conduisent forcément
drogues dures obligatoirement j'en ai
trop connu je suis comme une génération
qui a vu naître tout j'ai trop tôt les
années 70 où toutes les tranches de les
y est arrivé
mike brant qui se lance dans dans le sol
par dessus sa terrasse en croyant qu'ils
étaient oiseaux et tous les mecs qui me
disait un jour digne de ce qui se passe
à hommage à ray très con jouer on l'a
retrouvé mort d'une overdose dans les
chiottes de l'alcazar non non ça ils ont
commencé par jose douce ils ont testé
fini par parler de drogues dures et ils
sont donc pas drôle du tout à beauvais
non l'amour inverse
est ce que vous croyez à l'innocence de
michael jackson non non c'est à dire
arriver à une tête grande vouloir il ne
sait plus où le moral s'arrête doit
s'arrêter
c'est à dire pour lui et tant de michael
jackson c'est à dire un dieu vivant n'a
plus de repères il ya plus de repères et
donc in fine il croit qu'il peut faire
tout ce qu'il veut
un que personne ne lui reprochera jamais
rien est ce que vous croyez si je vous
dis je vous crois
2 vous passez pour un être un peu
démoniaque dans le sens dans le sens
simplement que vous avez un verbe assez
terrifiant que vous savez un peu
déshabiller l'âme des gens et mais au
fond de vous même et un ep
c'est un tas doit venir d'une dan
atavisme raciale ou deux il ya un être
qui a vécu beaucoup de choses et par
vaux réincarnation vous avez été une
personnalité extraordinaire dans le
passé était quoi avant les gt gt2 au
moins de vie que je connais il y en a
une ou j'étais un galérien je ramais sur
une galère c'était horrible
dans l'antiquité gréco-romaine et une
autre vie au moyen âge ou j'attaque un
château fort et je prends un boulet dans
le ventre
j'en suis persuadé si la gastro que les
champignons hallucinogènes
d'avoir 2
est ce que vous croyez que l'homme
descend du singe à je suis à peu près
sûr que c'est un singe évolué est ce que
vous croyez que lagaf est le chaînon
manquant
je pense que oui est ce que vous croyez
que la gauche a une chance en 2007
j'espère que non elle se croyait aux
extraterrestres les extraterrestres oui
pourquoi serions nous seuls donc
peut-être plus loin très loin
c'est scier temps de paix qu'en
fouillant n'a pas trouvé vraiment mon
problème c'est connu les tirs et le
problème c'est qu'on peut fouiller dans
la banlieue à marcher maamar cheveux non
c'est encore et à quelques millions
d'années lumière on peut pas fouiller
années pourquoi pas est ce que vous
croyez au paradis
je sais pas je suis pas sûr que les
portes dans ce conte ouverte non modeste
non non mais vous me dire ça t'as raison
vaut mieux jouer profil bas patrouillent
à une bouteille est ce que vous croyez
qu'un jour vous serez maire de paris
j'espère bien ouais
est ce que vous croyez que l'homme est
un loup pour l'homme
oui est ce que vous croyez qu'il faut
interdire les mariages gays le mot
mariage me choque un peu qu'ils vivent
ensemble ça me choque pas ce que vous
croyez que le cannabis doit être
légalisée en freinant tout simplement
tout simplement parce que c'est la
première marche vers quelque chose qui
est épouvantable et je le dis et thierry
vous le savez parfaitement bien
j'ai un frère qui est je connais votre
frère dé ce qui est un homme
parfaitement intelligent s'appelle
françois qui a écrit des livres marca
tout à fait vrai et qui a à sa vie qui a
été bouffé par la drogue sait mais c'est
le cannabis qu'il en est le héros des
arts
d'après eux c'est plutôt l'hérault quand
même soyons numéro après oui mais non il
ya plein de gens qui fument 99% des gens
qui fument du cannabis qui n'est pas que
vous en fumée mais ces gens là ne vont
pas forcément non c'est vrai mais l'
alcool tabac etc
on m'a pas tout interdire marrant c'est
qu'on m'interdit pas ce qui fait plaisir
aux viticulteurs france j'ai un ami qui
est atteint de sclérose en plaques
c'est la seule chose qui lui est
conseillé recommandé par les singes
cannabis bien sûr un ami qui apparaît
sclérose dans la salle tranquille cela
chez le canadien
est ce que vous croyez que ça va
s'arranger au moyen-orient je l'espère
je pense qu'il ya eu quelques pas qui ce
ski sont pas mauvais mais je suis assez
triste et même révolté de ce que j'ai
entendu quand le président iranien a
annoncé l'achat alors là ça ça m'a
écoeuré
ouais vous croyez qu'il faut bombarder
l'iran avant que l'iran nous bombarde
je n'ai pas jusque là mais je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à ce qu'il
n'ait pas la bombe atomique
nous croyons votre prochain quand on est
chirurgien on pense que tous les hommes
sont un peu son prochain on est là pour
ça c'est de l'humanisme croyant vous oui
sont bien suer de voir un surtout les
îles pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus